(beeping)
(upbeat electronic music)
- And, of course nobody's here,
I'll be zapping in the room first.
(beeping)
- Hey Lightning.
- [Lightning] There we go, finally
- Hey, hey buddy.
- How's it going?
- I'm doing well, sorry
I'm a little bit late,
I was having a Yurbomatte with the old
archnemesis, The Composter.
- Wazzaa!
- [Lightning] Haha, I love that.
- [Chill] Still funny. Still funny.
- Never gets old, right?
- Guys, I don't want to, I
don't want to get everybody
too excited, I just got a
couple new dream catchers.
I hung 'em up so the
place is looking great.
- Is your super power to
bore your enemies to death?
(Lightning laughing)
(beeping)
- Hey guys.
- This is my friend Complacent Man.
- Oh, I'm already tired of you guys.
- I know what your, I know
immediately what your deal is.
- I was watching somebody
rob a bank. It was, yeah.
- You watched somebody rob a bank?
- [Complacent Man] Well
yeah, I could've stopped 'em
but I gotta all that Krav Maga and shit.
It's a lotta work.
- Hey, uh, Complacent?
Do you play a lot of multiplayer games?
- Oh sure, I'm all over it.
I've watched loads of people play.
- You've watched,
you've watched 'em.
- But you haven't actually.
- Well it's a lot of
energy to push everything.
- We got a game so get ready here guys.
Listen, here are the rules.
Complacent, you haven't
played with us before
so I'm gonna run through them
real quick like with you.
No shotguns. No camping. No superpowers.
- I'm gonna have a great
time with my friends.
(both groaning and mumbling)
- Let's play.
(gunfire)
- I'm kind of (farts)
shitting myself right now
I mean literally. (farts)
- The best part of playing
this, I swear to God,
is that we can legally kill people.
Especially teenagers.
- Where are you jerks?
Trying to locate you.
- [Complacent] Oh, right.
- [Lighting] On your six,
on your four, on your five,
on your eight, on your
seven, on your nine.
Stop moving!
- [Complacent] I just
threw a grenade at a bench.
That's cool.
- Okay, um. You can throw those at people,
it'd be pretty rewarding.
- Ah! Murder!
Damnit.
- Is it just me or do any of you get laid
from saving people?
- Oh I just shot a trash can.
- I do like every half hour,
every 45 minutes or so.
- Really?
- Yeah the issue is I come too quick.
It's the curse of the
whole lightening thing.
- You're killing my buzz, to be honest.
- I'm really horny but not really.
- Guys I, you know, just maybe
you can learn by example,
I just killed a guy
with a rocket launcher.
Got us 100 points.
Uh, hey Complacent I think
if you would try something
a little, you know, more similar to that,
you'd feel great about how you did.
- Oh. I know everything.
- I'm not saying I know everything.
- How do you press the button... so hard?
- You just, you apply a little
bit of pressure with your
finger, come on man.
Get your fuckin' head in the game.
- Ok button,
you have 3 seconds.
- How do you press the button?
(laughing)
- Three seconds, button.
- Can we get anyone else?
Can we get anyone else?
I'm sorry to not be chill.
- Wow, wow, wow.
- Oh, wow.
- Can we get Professor Dog?
- I'm dead again.
- Ahhh icicle storm!
- [Complacent] Cold in here.
- [Flashback] Hey we won!
(burps) Yeah, I'm gonna go jerk off.
(upbeat electronic music)
(pixelated noises)